guys this podcast is starting out with a
special announcement but first i brought
the banjo back oh no
[Music]
that's the first announcement
the first of three announcements is that
i only have two remaining amounts
my second announcement is that the first
announcement definitely counts as an
announcement all right it's
just making that clear
announcing your announcements counts as
announcements that would be my second
announcement
so that's the first announcement welcome
to the corridor cast everybody
uh it's good to be back we've got uh
around the around the pod today we've
got myself around the campfire nick
laurent
sam gorski
you know me from such as
from
avatar
and tiny guns yes yeah
um and then of course nico hi eco i need
your introduction
i should legally change my name
needs no introduction
first name just
um okay so guess what's happening uh
next week for those of you who haven't
found out yet don't follow us on
instagram don't don't listen to the
podcast very often we'll guess what
we've got a very special announcement
for you sam what is it
well
i am excited to announce that next week
i'll be going
on my first
hot air balloon ride
that's not the announcement oh gosh dang
it
look sorry the announcement is that i
have decided that i will go on a hot air
balloon ride how do you decide where are
you doing this did you get the groupon
or something uh no actually i really
want to do i was thinking about this the
last two weeks and it's like you know
skydiving could be pretty fun but a hot
air balloon ride is like all the thrill
without the velocity
so very low risk of death very low risk
very mild way to get incredibly high
[Laughter]
anyways um the real announcement is that
son of a dungeon is coming out next week
son of a dungeon
and
it's cool it's coming along the episodes
are great people say they laughed at
them and they thought they were quote
cool so the reviews are in
the reviews
people said they
laughed and
peculiar problem with son of a dungeon
in that
episode two is like exceptionally good
but um it's not episode one you know i
know the best
i mean
don't get me wrong yeah all the episodes
are good but like the one we're like oh
this is actually really pretty solid
is episode two i know that's what i've
been saying where it's like the first
episode is fine but the second episode
is where it like really
gets like a turbo charge and everything
gets really intense and really funny all
at the same time
um yeah so
but that's the whole point of a series
is that there's multiple episodes
and yeah there's eight episodes there's
eight so yeah wow
also uh
when we actually release the episode
first episode it's gonna be live on
youtube
second episode
will also be available on the site
same time oh cool we're going to watch
comments in real time on the podcast
with carmichael
as the episode is released to the wild
and then we're going to turn that into a
podcast that's gonna come out the next
day so a week from today when this
podcast comes out thursday
there's gonna be another one where
you're gonna get live
director and showrunner commentary
from
sam and carmichael
so
sam doesn't even know it look at him he
doesn't even know
well
i'm also like out of town next week so
i'm thinking about how i'll make this
work
[Laughter]
we can pre-record some reactions from
sam
didn't do it
that was okay that was a failed live
announcement so
i guess you're getting that we need to
come up with another announcement now
yeah i mean we could just do it the
following week it's just not going to be
as impactful because it's not going to
be like as the
episode is going live
yeah which is what i wanted maybe i
could just remote in and just freaking
it's what it's like an hour so yeah just
an hour
yeah
hopefully you can yeah we'll figure that
out all right cool plenty of time once
you're up there you know yeah yeah
hopefully you can you do it from an air
balloon let's that would be the ultimate
i
won't be honest i i have an announcement
which is that i will not be on a hot air
balloon as the series premieres come on
let's make this happen
let's get you on a hot air balloon no no
it's not going to work like there's no
noon pacific next wednesday oh my god
i don't know if i can orchestrate that
but i'll try to get you up in the air
you'll have the you'll have a phone and
you'll be looking you'll be like hey
guys hey what up i'm in a balloon hey i
can't i can't really i don't really know
what they're out of the episode and i
can't really hear anybody but i'm up in
a balloon
yeah and we're like trying to do
troubleshooting like freaking like sam
your audio's not working
it's like hold on did you mute your mic
oh wait hold on your video
michael sam the comments
[Laughter]
let's see if we can make that happen you
can do a podcast where you're
exclusively in a balloon yeah balloon
wait what if we do a podcast where each
one of us is in a separate balloon
white god what if the technology exists
hey many of you podcast listeners out
there having to own a hot air balloon
company you want to sponsor a podcast
i'm being serious but i i also highly
doubt that any pod hot air balloon
operators are listening to
air balloons us demographic
let me tell you dude
there's at least a hundred of them out
there
yeah
apparently temecula where christian's
from is a hot spot for hot air balloons
get some good pumps
it's a real hot spot
capital of california right there
it is man there's a lot of ballooners
out there um so they call them balloon
captains
all right
once you're three miles above the
surface does it does it does the same
international laws apply
yes exactly so is there anything
it's like
be careful what you say
that's the admiral right next to you
i was like oh sorry i bumped into him
like 20 times already there's like
nowhere else behind me this is his fleet
every balloon you see he controls
yeah but it's a big basket okay i know
but
depending yeah dude is the captain the
last one to go down with the balloon
he gives the he gives the parachutes to
everybody else
[Laughter]
does he keep like he keeps like
kid-sized parachutes and they're on the
side they're on the side of the basket
no they're just smaller balloons
he's got smaller balloons hanging on the
side
of the basket just like a ship would
so i'm probably just incredibly stupid
but i've always found it weird that
don't you like you put to make the
balloon go down you like put weights off
the side of it or something right you
like you get the sandbags and you like
throw them off that's in the movies you
put them out how is that changing that's
what i'm saying like it seems like it
makes no sense at all no it's just you
just
stop and just stop eating the air inside
of the balloon swearing's like
outside that's what i'm saying
[Laughter]
oh my god there's this clip i saw he was
angry he's just an irish dude he's like
it's like a it's like a educational show
and he's like here's a question you
never thought about
what weighs more kilogram of steel or a
kilogram of feathers and then like a
little timer pops up like you're
supposed to think about he's like that's
right a kilogram of steel
wait and then the rest of the video is
just people's
people one by one coming up to like no
no no no
[Laughter]
is heavier than feathers
anyways
oh god it reminds me that anyways dude
so uh
any other that's what we're gonna do
nick i i just some more questions about
hot air balloon physics but you know
we'll we'll get to that another time
when we have an actual balloon captain
come on i mean how how do they work nick
dude sam's about to find out report back
yeah i'm going to find out let us know
what happens when you take that
you never actually answered this
question are you going on a hot air
balloon ride or not i
i do not have
a ticket to go on a balloon yet but i am
determined
still to go on this hot air balloon ride
he's going to be is this like in the
near future that you were determined
today next week this is next week next
week as early as next week if things
work out
did you just clear your schedule for a
week to prospectively go on a balloon
ride you got me you got me i cleared my
entire week next week to see when i
impossibly impulsively just wake up and
go it's a it's the day
are you going somewhere in particular
sam yeah i'm going up to northern
minnesota
oh
yeah going up to there are hot air
balloons up there
that's the thing i know
there are where like itasca county
like uh yeah near grand rapids
minnesota which is okay
yeah it's like three hours north of the
cities four hours
i don't know where the bit is that
considered part of the iron range
yeah it's grand rapids adjacent adjacent
to it okay
exciting
yes glad you could update all the
listeners
yes
as you can tell i'm incredibly excited
so you're going on a balloon ride over
lake superior
maybe
and at that time maybe it would be on
the podcast are you are you going to
make the sandwiches before you go on the
balloon or you're going to kind of just
freestyle them up in the air that's
actually a good question what do you do
if you're hungry i do that's why i'm
asking and i thought you had planned out
do they like check your bag to make sure
you're not carrying anything too heavy
yeah don't worry you have to go you go
through a metal detector yeah they have
to have to go through
i'll bring like a whole puget up there
i'm like sir i have to be live streaming
in a few moments
please refrain from using your
electronic devices during taxi takeoff
and landing yeah
this is like mike might interfere with
the radios yeah oh there is a balloon
mode on your phone if you have
[Music]
oh my god can we just make a whole
podcast about [ __ ] hair balloons
i don't think anybody any one of us can
top sam's balloon joke right there
that's probably the best one
let's just stop
all right so so
what was your other announcement you
said you had three oh well we'll get to
that i'll save it for the end um
yeah so just to bring it full circle
here uh yeah cool show son of a dungeon
coming out very soon it's funny watching
tonight after playing it and it's like
wow like we were just really on top of
it we knew exactly what to do we're so
coordinated and then like at the end of
episode two like actually play some
table talk and it's like oh that's right
oh
yeah
everything else
yeah we cut out
three out of every one hour yeah for
every hour you see there's three cuts
holy yeah so it's but it it's like how
you do it yes like but as as far as like
a storytelling standpoint is concerned
like that's really freaking efficient
you know imagine the amount of time
spent working on like a script or
filming stuff on set how long that takes
versus that
true yeah yeah it's crazy and like it's
so it's so that way it like it has the
pace of uh like a movie basically where
it's just story beats happening
happening happening
um that doesn't say it has the page it
has the pace of a television show yeah
it definitely does like i i was feeling
like oh this is actually making me feel
like i'm watching a movie not as like i
feel like i'm watching movies and like
it's triggering the same emotional ups
and downs that movie triggers in me
and whenever when each episode ended
i immediately got excited to to continue
the story yeah so yeah the uh the
the scenes jake between you and sam
where you guys are in character talking
back and forth are
like actually legitimately funny
like the rhythms that you guys like fall
into are really good yeah
especially love the the
evil count character or whatever i
forget
funny yeah
oh yeah when we're in the bar it's great
and you're talking you're talking to me
about the the
tadpoles yeah and then you're like you
convinced him to go drink it in his
treasure room
[Laughter]
oh man and then you're in there nico
yeah i want to describe how but you're
in the room and he's trying to swat you
yeah yeah
it's good it's pretty funny yeah um it's
crazy but like uh so i
don't have the exact number but there's
like about
30 green screen shots per episode and
then about 60 to 70 individually you
like unique full cg shots
per episode as well um yeah and it's
pretty wild if you think about like the
volume of footage that we can like vfx
we can put into it because
like the the shots in unreal take longer
to set up than they do to render
which um you know normally it's like
more even with like 3d work sometimes
where it's like oh yeah i work on this
for an hour or two and if i want it to
like be animated and and render it out
it'll take an hour or two to
render out but this is it's just like
seconds so
just flying through these shots and are
you even using a render station are you
just doing it all night on my computer
like i just i work for an hour too and
then i hit render and i take like a
15-minute break basically then i come
back and i've got like
a dozen shots ready to go
awesome
it's pretty cool
yeah it's pretty great it's really easy
to understand where we are in the maps
what's happening that's there yeah
and that's always been my problem with
watching other dnd shows is you
you i mean you can imagine it you you
end up coming up with it in your head
just like you're reading a book but
seeing it immediately just kind of like
i try and watch any other show and you
pop in and it's like like sure yeah
maybe you don't know the whole story
you're not starting at the you know the
first episode but even still it's like
it's really hard to catch up and go like
wait where are we
like what's happening who are we talking
to who are these characters like and
with this it's like that constant visual
reminder of like oh you're in this guy's
office or you're in a dining hall or
you're in a cave or it's like there's
you know you get so much more
information so quickly are you gonna do
a an intro
that contextual intro at each
at the top of the first episode or like
a recap
well
there's just like a lot of things we
talked about that aren't at the
beginning of the first episode i noticed
which is basically like
who i mean we kind of go over this but
it's very brief
and it's just like who are these guys
why are they doing this yes we have this
absolutely we have that that and you may
have missed it because in one of the
exports there's there's the whole
fly through yeah sequence that peter
rendered um okay and that's like about a
minute long and in that minute there's
vo that
okay yeah it's like here's all the
exposition
you guys are
monster hunters blah blah and you gotta
yeah i don't think i don't have that i
don't have that version yeah i did the
same thing jake i i watched it and none
of that was in there it just started and
it's like all right guys so we're here
in the woods and like okay all right you
guys walk up okay yeah i was like sam
maybe we should like have like a title
card or
an intro like
yeah no there's a whole freaking thing
yeah
and then you showed me and i'm like oh
okay that's a badass
it all makes sense no that makes sense
yeah so it's pretty sweet
it's pretty cool
can't wait doesn't work do you think
people are going to want to see a second
season honestly and and you know with
them
we almost owe it towards two sides right
there by the way i just like to point
out sam when yes then you gave an ex
aspirated sigh
and then he started talking to pause and
he gave one more exasperated sigh and
then he went into well i can explain so
i
i i sigh whenever i sigh that means
i have an angel loses its weight i
thought
i don't know i'm serious i'm very
serious like i audibly like whenever i
think of something that's stressful or
something like that i i just it happens
now
but the reason i sighed is because well
first off
almost like regardless of like how the
show does
you know there's this time investment
that's been put into it uh for example
we filmed it in february
and it's being released in september you
know and that's a lot of months to work
on a dnd show and
a big reason for why it took so long
was because of the virtual camera system
that was put together for the green
screen that took basically like two
months like i wasted so much freaking
time getting that stuff working
and
it barely worked at the end um so that
that was a big
big chunk of time spent there but then
also like the entire concept of like
well what are we going to do
with these models like how do we
you know show more shots of this like
putting it together and unreal and all
this this learning curve of you know
taking these huge models and rendering
them in real time and blah blah and so
now that i'm
i feel like i'm on the other side of it
now um i'm i'm rendering out the
establishing shots for like the seventh
episode right now that's very close
there's eight episodes so there's eight
episodes and now that i've
you know i'm i can finally kind of look
back on the process and go oh my god
like we we could have done this
so much faster if we would have done
like x y z
uh
and
so we could we could we could have done
it in half the time
with with what i know now so it's it's
like it's it's almost a thing of
knowing how cool the show is and what
time we put into it
it's like worth it to just make the
second season because of how
much more efficient it can get and
i don't know i just
yeah carmichael is saying the same thing
i think there's something there yeah he
was saying the same thing just about his
process to get to the
you know near final edits and
the capture the
the dumping process the
daily process like the assembly process
just all the way through on the editing
side i mean i i really hope people like
it and i hope it does well by whatever
metrics we kind of set for ourselves
here because it's
you know it's the first
exclusive it's the first big exclusive
show crew cuts technically is already a
big exclusive show i mean 100 episodes
that's a
ton of time it's been coming out for you
know a year
um but this is the first narrative
yeah and there's a ton of like cg you
know it's like it's got a lot of
spectacle to it and blah blah and it
definitely taps into
uh like a popular you know culture
thing d d yeah yeah so hopefully it does
well and then we can make a second
season in a fraction of the time and
it'd be really cool
yeah i'm hoping we can film it like well
ideally people like it we film it top of
the year and then it's out by
it'll be out by like
yeah definitely even so like the virtual
camera thing too like i can't say
specifically what this is publicly but
someone i got in contact with some a
group of people
who are basically
making hardware that solves all the
virtual production issues that we were
facing from like frame drops and how do
you sync your camera with the background
and all that stuff to the point where
it's it's effectively like a
plug-and-play system
um
and we'll be testing it here in the
studio in a matter of weeks basically
but that solves a ton of issues a lot of
headaches we
had to like cut multiple shots
frequently because we'd lose tracking or
something would happen
and this fixes all that so it makes it
faster and then the whole like
digitizing the maps process like photo
scanning that stuff and figuring that
process out
was kind of a nightmare because
we were like how big do these maps need
to be how how are we going to scale them
how do we clean up all this like
geometry when we get these 3d files of
the maps
um so wait the the box doesn't do that
though no the box is no no no but okay
there's a whole learning curve and
process of all right hey i'm gonna
yeah photo scan four huge maps that have
multiple pieces and parts and
we're chopping them up like the doors
doors
literally sucks doors suck
you
we photo scanned doors on the map and
had to cut them out of the 3d model
afterwards to
to make it all work and even like
cutting out one door it's like just
just like
half hour to 45 minutes of work just
just just kind of making one door move
movable
yeah and so yeah
there's a whole episode where all we do
is move doors
yeah
it's the door
what
i remember sam a few days ago you were
saying like i'm just gonna scan all
these characters and polycam yeah i did
that and then you literally re-rendered
every single shot they're in in just
like a matter of minutes yep they're all
done
so yesterday that was the other thing
too so we used reality capture for the
maps which is great for huge
massive high polygon
uh through photo scans because you can
control like you want 16k textures you
want four 8k textures like how do you
want to break this tons of control but
you have to use a like a normal camera
for that and uh so when you're scanning
like the actual miniatures
it's really tough because you know a
lens has depth of field and blurry stuff
in your image translates to blurry
textures um so i basically rescanned
like the main like npc cast with polycam
which is just on your phone
and they're super high quality and they
look way way better and so because it's
all in unreal i can basically scan these
models
from scratch
re-import them into unreal basically
replacing the old models
and then without having to touch a
single thing in any scene i just bring
open all the sequences from the first i
did literally
75 of the sequences from the first four
episodes i just dragged them into the
render queue and hit render and walked
away and i replaced all the files this
morning so the first four episodes now
has
higher quality like character models
uh
and it like it took like an hour and a
half
to render it all it's like it's insane
but like you do that like once again if
we were in blender or cinema 4d that
would have been a nightmare
to try and do you have to open every
individual file and you're like okay
well
you know you have to then take the new
model and put it in the old position
you know you can't just like quickly
replace a file you know it's more like
using after effects or premiere where
you're like oh i have a piece of footage
i'm just going to re-import this footage
at a new like file path and then it just
replaces it there in the timeline it's
it's basically the equivalent of that
but for 3d
right um so it's yeah super fast it's
really cool it's really efficient
definitely could not be doing the show
without that
that's awesome
yeah i um
well i'm glad the tools are coming along
i mean yeah it was kind of like hey do
you do we do this cutting edge thing
with uh in a way that we've never really
created anything before and you just
kind of have to i mean that's how we've
done anything though you just take it on
faith and you you know you know you know
you know the intended outcome you know
the technology is
stable enough to at least
get a proof of concept
and then yeah you know we did that
i mean and you've been doing that for
i mean what was the first like virtual
reality mix thing that we started with i
can't even remember at this point it was
like two years ago
[Music]
was it what was it it was no it was it
was the uh it was the uh um
lion thing no it was the area 51 game oh
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah okay so that was
the first that was the first one that
was like here's here's a game engine
yeah let's mess with that
that was very glitchy i remember i know
oh my god it was all the way to stop
sleeping around yeah but it was also
like unity because unity is like a lot
more bare bones than unreal is mm-hmm
well there was also sakura digger
oh yeah i guess that actually that's the
first one rest in
peace graveyard yeah it's totally gone
it doesn't exist anymore yep 100 gone
rip
that's what he wants you to think
yeah
so
yeah i mean we knew that it was gonna be
a bit of a challenge but uh
i'm i'm just i mean
i'm just glad that we went through
and it's you know especially
from a technical side you and carmichael
and spencer and natalie just going
through all of that and then
now with these season two tools
it's like okay we know we have all this
extra knowledge but we only need to be
able to do this yeah so
it should be it should be more efficient
we'll see it will be it'll be great
it will be awesome doing two seasons a
year would be the ideal i think for that
if it can be efficient
it's possible
it's possible i think maybe sam's time
yeah if someone else is getting two
could render out all the shots then you
have easier obviously yeah it's not
gonna it's not you're you're not gonna
be able to just do exactly what you're
doing for this season for every season
not not not if we're gonna scale it
yeah but
i mean look at vfx artists react like
you look at the first episode of that
show and it's kind of janky not kinda
it's so very cheap yeah it's super janky
the thumbnail is janky like the whole
thing and
so it was the first model t ford you
know it was just like hey exactly the
cave shitty car yeah
because the react show is completely
equivalent i remember we initially
filmed the
microphones in the room so it's just
like boom
like room tone audio like people
coughing and like
because everybody's working behind us
everyone's literally right around you
it's like hey did we didn't we lose
audio for an entire one or maybe yeah
yeah
yeah
the on-camera audio do we have on camera
audio as a backup we do we do okay cool
just double checking on live on the
podcast yeah
[Laughter]
this stuff's kind of double as well
we could do a room mic we have a room
mic apparently kind of yeah there's one
on the camera yeah so that's that's the
same camera
yeah that'd be such i'm glad we haven't
had any like
ill realms the closest we had to like uh
don't say that technically there's some
word i cannot sorry never mind never
mind
no
you're right there hasn't since that day
i was traumatized
by hearing that episode and i was like
never again that's good that's how
that's how people learn it honestly is
trauma
a little bit
real
for real yeah
it's very powerful learning tool yeah
uh nico how's your edit going we talked
about it a bit two weeks ago or last
week
yeah i um it was late to the podcast
because i was working on it i was
messing around with color grading and
that kind of stuff but yeah it's super
cool
um but you know what
i don't know it's this is so far out and
like
i feel like i can't talk about much more
i can just say that
too much yet
i don't want to die it's cool
yeah
that's cool it's all what's the coolest
thing about it
i'm gonna leave it at that
not even no no no no just give me some
time
it's not time to build hyphen i don't
want to steal the thunder effects in it
uh i don't know
i have multiple ideas because they
actually isn't there a plug-in for that
at this point there's a yeah there is
like the best one ever made by video
co-pilot for free but okay uh the light
servers themselves are so bright that
there's also potentially a way
to do the lightsaber effect without ever
having to do anything by hand and just
key the image but
i also don't want to be lightsabers i
want them to be energy swords i want
them to be
different than lightsabers to some
degree where they feel a little bit more
dangerous a little bit more deadly a
little bit sharper you know it's just
lightsabers were invented in the 70s and
they really haven't changed their style
too much since then i feel like there's
a lot to be done in that space
like innovation around energy swords is
a little stagnant these days
like has there been like a lightsaber
style weapon and anything else
like i'm just too afraid everyone's too
afraid because they're like that's a
lightsaber in video games there are
they're all over the place in video
games
i mean it's just glowing magic swords i
guess yeah it's just you know why not
more color fringe i mean
you know we can do better than that
i'm going to try to do better than that
ammo we will
yeah we will do better you guys
innovated with that video more just
going
chrome rods onto each one
attract some hairy lightsabers dude
i think there's stuff you can do with
like you know it's plasma energy it's
being focused or something you can do
like stuff with like spitting globs of
energy or sparks um you know light beams
you know having a tip
ambitious vibe
a tip that's not round but sharp instead
you know nothing like a rounded tip
making it sharp i mean come on this is a
low-hanging fruit it's been sitting
there for somebody to walk along and
pluck from the tree so serrated i'm
gonna pluck a blade serrated
are you going to give it actual metallic
sound effects
[Laughter]
sound effects
well you could also do like a cool like
particle system thing too where it's
like you just go like all right i'm
going to like
constrain this like vortex with
particles or something on it where it's
just like just swirling stuff happening
yeah i agree there'll be a lot of
tracking a lot of 3d work
yeah we're probably not going to do that
but yeah no i think there is a lot of
stuff you could actually do with it can
you tell an ai to do it
i could
i don't know how to get back though
could be interesting error
it's just a perfect lightsaber effect
it's like i just think it's like all the
all the ai would know is lightsabers so
it's just going to be you just showed a
bunch of star wars movies and you're
like so these guys are fighting with
sticks
you know what to do ai
and i just make some lightsabers you
know honestly that you could probably do
that [ __ ] hilarious it makes
everything that's like a pole in this a
couple grad students could probably
knock that out in a few months
no you just show behind the scenes from
star wars yeah where they're using
sticks
did you get them before and after
it turns every stick people are just
walking through telephones yes there's
like stop signs that are on lightsabers
yeah yeah perfect i did start looking
into slow generators over the weekend
this is what ren would say if he was in
the
futurology segment
[Music]
so
in the future
the future
no one will have toes
they'll have been absorbed into the foot
i like all every like single futuristic
prediction what humans are gonna be like
completely forgets the whole like your
physical manifestation is due to like
what leads to more reproduction it's
like how would not having toes make you
reproduce
when was the last time you used your
toes
not having toes would only be a thing in
the future if it actually was like more
attractive to women it's like ooh that
guy's toes are real short
i've met women that don't like toes that
guy that guy only has two toes he
doesn't even have any toes
i want to have his children boom that's
how you end up with no toast in the
future just do that millions of times
millions of times over thousands of
years
or whatever the robot couldn't the robot
scanning for people couldn't identify
the people without toes as humans so
they survived hence that's right yeah
all right well if one part of our bodies
were to de-evolve what would it be then
if it weren't toes what do we never use
brains
what about earlobes who needs earlobes
like what the [ __ ] does this pierced all
the time yeah but that's just
so arguably something that calibers
wouldn't wear earrings and then
maybe they'd end up missing on that well
don't your ears that's why we have mom
don't your earlobes help you capture
sound
like they resonate like this kind of no
like it hits it and it goes through this
like thing right here and then yeah
that's why it's curved like that
possibly yeah kind of i think so
i don't know how see here's the thing i
don't know how does that mean i can hear
better than nico
i mean i know i know your ears like
fleshy cup around the hole in your head
like helps direct sound into your ear
and makes it better but i do wonder how
mechanically efficient it is
like is this like it's just like
you know a god god-like perfect design
of like acoustic resonance or is it just
like weird fleshy bits that are a little
wrinkled and they don't need to be
you know like if these are perfect like
satellite dishes something better we're
all works in progress
it's just always changing we're still in
hair why the [ __ ] do we have hair
what do you think gbt3 has to say about
the future
yeah there you go here we go
get it
oh boy so i'm gonna i'm gonna give it a
really good prompt dear computer what is
the future like here's the prompt the
prompt is
[Music]
we asked a really smart computer what it
thought the future would be like period
here are its top 10 predictions all
right another classic top 10 gbt3
here we go article generator let's go
and this is puppy mechanics actually
all right let's try it again
can't do it one virtual reality
bio hacking
three weird space travel four robots
five new cities
six flying cars seven better homes eight
3d printing nine self-driving cars ten
advanced a.i that's it
i mean
number one is ai and number ten is wait
what do you understand will look like in
the future in the future we'll all be
really really bored
you'll be able to summon a robot servant
to do anything for you
pyramids will finally have some
competition
what does that mean
we'll have a more efficient way to get
around town you'll have a personalized
soundtrack for every moment of your life
i'm down with that you won't have to
worry about getting lost
we'll finally have a cure for cancer
the internet will be a much more
enjoyable experience there won't be any
more traffic jams you'll be able to
travel anywhere in the world in 15
minutes
[Laughter]
you'll also be able to read minds
eat anything you want never gain weight
skip straight to the front of any line
yeah you get a chair that massages you
and moves you around to keep you
comfortable
and you store your stuff in the cloud
you can do that
you'll be able to charge your phone by
breathing on it
then you won't just be a mouth breather
in the future you'll be a phone charger
too yeah that's really good that's a
good one
i like how it's like doesn't understand
the concept of like cutting to the front
of a line if everyone can cut to the
front of the line yeah can you ask it
what humans will look like as we evolve
oh yeah oh yeah yeah in the year three
no one would we asked the world's
smartest computer what it thought humids
would okay would look like
in the year 20
the world's three smartest computer
what it thought humans would look like
in the year 3000 period here's what it
had to tell us
all right i'm excited for this earlobes
20 bucks
toes is definitely gonna be on there
toes has been on the chopping block for
generations we need webb's back honestly
swimming powers let's go
all right gpt3
i'm excited
maybe you need to give it a top 10 again
i want to ask it also like what are some
obscure hot air balloon laws yeah
or
just hot air balloon laws
in general because oh my god it's all
just about sex dolls
[Laughter]
maybe we need to rephrase it as like
human beings uh if human beings keep
evolving here's how our bodies will
change
if
human beings keep evolving
here's the most noticeable changes
you'll see colon
all right here we go healthier yes
more attractive more tolerant more
considerate obviously yes
okay here we go
one we'll be able to live in water
two we'll see the end of disease and
cancer three will live to be around 200
years old
or we'll all be like super mutants oh
we'll be like five
we'll have the power to fly six okay
we'll also be able to teleport
we can move objects with our minds we
can control minds we can change our
appearances we'll have the ability to
breathe fire can we change our minds
we'll be able to survive in space see
the future communicate with animals
plants machines the earth the universe
what
multiverse wow with everything
wow
we'll be able to change the past and
future and travel through time
and we can determine our own destinies
create life change matter
and the list is it's we have a 30 item
list now so we're gods in the future
it just turns into god mode there okay
okay what do we complain about once
we're gods can you ask at that and see
what it gives us here's the top 10
things that gods complain about
[Laughter]
here are the top 10 things that gods
complain about
[Music]
one not taking him seriously
[Laughter]
[Music]
two saying we're not sure if god is real
please saying we don't know what god
wants
or saying god is not interested in our
lives okay these are like real
complaints i want like a greek
church i love the greek god complaints
yes
i'm so wholesome
maybe i'll change it from gods to
deities
yeah
or roman gods
omnipotent beings
all right here's the top 10 things that
oh my god my typos are all
that doesn't matter because otherwise it
learns uh actually if you put typos into
just make the rest of the writing
sloppier
all right
worshipers sacrificing animals they
complain about that sacrificing other
worshipers
when people
offer a small offering
dude
when someone makes a small offering it's
like
fun
off the rails it's all about tiny
offerings and how annoying it is
yeah well
um
no no it's literally just the same thing
i was just down on earth you wouldn't
believe what they're giving away to us
these days
dude when people give offerings to other
deities for more than one day and do not
give
these do not give offerings to them
longer for longer than
yeah okay you got two days oh man oh man
anyways well sorry yeah we know just got
to interrupt the flow here with some
random ai [ __ ] no this is the futurology
segment yeah you just got to the box
this is the future futurology segment
i'm excited for the future now
that sounds cool yeah me too
i mean
i feel like the thing that kept me going
was looking forward to your hot air
balloon ride but now beyond that when
that's over the next thing i have to
look can we ask about what the top 10
obscure balloon ride laws are
oh yeah we can google that all right but
that's gonna be the end of our podcast
oh
okay should we talk about maybe like
what the hierarchy of like
balloon crewmen are truman
[Laughter]
i think what the wackiest balloon
accidents are
oh okay the wackiest thoughts ask it to
describe the ranking structure of
balloon culture
the authority structure of golden
culture
okay uh i'm gonna start with hot air
balloon
accidents
here are
the 10 most wacky hot air balloon
accidents that ever happened
i did delete it at all
i have to type it now
you can't just voice it a second time it
delete it i'm just typing it for
do you guys know about like the fast
typing method on your phone or just
swipe your fingers
command the structure
hot air balloon
hat air balloon command structure
oh no these are all just like legit
oh my gosh are they not wacky
like hitting power lines and bursting
the flames oh there we go the 10
wackiest hot air balloon accidents that
ever happened 10. the war of the air
in july of 1790
this is why it's seven by the way not
number one the french revolution was in
full swing the jacobins had
had control of the government and
thousands of
wait where does this go i want to see
the capture of the whole fleet of
balloons so uh
french citizens were being executed by
treason very dark time here
um and then what are the jacobins do you
know what these people are uh jacobians
already
i don't know no it's a faction in the
french revolution i'm sure okay so
they started an insurgency against the
government began burning down buildings
and killing people they sent soldiers to
put down the rebellion
uh and they were led by none other than
napoleon
the insurgents were trapped in a
fortified chateau in the outskirts of
paris okay they had plenty of food of
water so they were able to hold out for
several weeks gone apart napoleon that
that is decided to use his hot air
balloons to attack the chateau
oh here we go it came back around yeah
the first balloon he sent was filled
with explosives but the wind blew it off
course and it exploded
uh it exploded come on light oh it's
hanging up i'm on the edge of the city
the jacobian exploded
established uh
uh republicans
came to power because of the battle
prowess earned by sending balloons into
battle so yeah so he's basically a
glorified
clown so the next balloon was like
poison gas but it landed in the moat
around the chateau the soldiers in the
chateau thought it was the insurgents
trying to gas them so they opened fire
on the balloon to destroy it the last
hot air balloon bonaparte scent was
filled with his soldiers this is landed
on the roof of the chateau and we're
able to take it without any casualties
it's like yeah okay first balloon blew
up second one caught on fire let's put
people in the third one that sounds like
a great idea you're not gonna believe
number nine the hot air balloon of death
in 1849 an italian named luigi torelli
was the first person to use the hot air
balloon in a war well after napoleon
come on
uh he was previously in the french
military but he came to italy after
being expelled for being a revolutionary
i want to use balloons for everything
in italy he began experimenting with hot
air balloons and eventually began using
them in war
he used a hot air balloon with a bomb
attached to it to bomb the city of
venice
the bomb landed in a residential area
killing four people torelli was captured
and executed
he drops one bomb and gets executed
was a member of the radical part of the
revolution that uh promoted the reign of
terror
and eventually they were the like the ss
of the french revolution they were the
they were
number eight is certainly an accident he
accidentally got executed it's the
balloonists last flight it was the
august of 1852 a hot air balloon was
carrying an american girl named hannah
reed she was on her way to meet her
father at the great exposition
exhibition in london
she was accompanied by her 17 year old
brother john and a 15 year old french
girl named elizabeth
they were flying over the town of
heffert's shire
when the balloon began to descend
it was on a collision course with the
farm
the pilot desperately tried to steer it
away from the building it didn't work
and the balloon crashed into the
farmhouse everyone was killed this is
why you can't hijack balloons all right
it's dangerous [ __ ] yeah yeah those
becomes incredibly dangerous seven is
pretty good so far promise promising uh
it's called inventing a new sport
in 1866
there was a hot air balloon race it
started
in boston yeah
it ended in new york city and two of the
competitors in the race were american
brothers named william and john
jefferson jeffers jeffress
the brothers were confident that they
could win this race but they had no idea
how they would get to the finish line
they'd never flown a balloon before
they decided to cut the balloon they've
never flown a balloon before so they're
trying to get to the race and they
realized their balloon was too large to
transport by rail so they decided to cut
it in half and carry the pieces
on the train they carefully cut the
balloon in half using a hot knife
they removed the basket and tied the
balloon pieces to a flat wagon they
successfully transported the balloon to
the finish line
oh
however they were disqualified because
they had not actually flown the balloon
to the finish line
the balloon was then cut up again and
sold to the public
uh-oh
uh-oh juicy number six the hot air
balloon accident that wasn't an accident
18-23 a group of british army officers
back in 1800's again they were attending
a dinner party at the helm of colonel
crichton the office was having a great
time until a hot air balloon crashed
into the house the balloon was carrying
a young couple who were to be married
the next day everyone in the house was
killed including the bride-to-be
who was decapitated by the balloon's
basket
the accident was covered up by the
government to prevent a panic
[Laughter]
people find out about this they're going
to do it i imagine a hot air balloon
it's going to be panicking in the
streets
but instead everyone was killed and she
got decapitated
and it wasn't an accident
all right we're getting hot
number five the balloonist who got cold
feet
it was december 1808 a hot air balloon
race was held at the county fair in
london it was a fairly
key event which is why it attracted a
lot of attention
people was like i really want to chill
out
so there can we go it's like nationwide
there were two men that were supposed to
fly one of the balloons but they decided
at the last minute they were not going
to participate in the race however a
young 14 year old boy named william
russell was standing nearby when he
overheard the men talking he asked if
they would let him fly the balloon they
agreed and the boy took off with the
balloon
the balloon was supposed to fly for a
few miles however the boy flew the
balloon for nearly 30 miles and landed
safely he was rewarded a gold medal for
bravery
are you sure this isn't gpg that wasn't
hold on we're going the scout who flew
too high
um
i don't want to rush it
these are good they're all good
oh boy well what happened to the scout
that flew too high well it was 1880
obviously and a hot air balloon
there's a hot air balloon in new york
city and it was the largest hot air
balloon ever built no 3 000 cubic meters
of hot air that's a lot and it's soared
to a height of a thousand feet it's not
very high it was ever fur it was the
first time a hot air balloon ever flew
that high
however the balloon was too large too
large to fly in most weather conditions
so it had to be flown in the most
optimal conditions
and its flight was postponed several
times because of bad weather sensible
and on the 17th of september the weather
was perfect and the balloon took off
rose to a thousand feet but caught in a
wind storm
he tried to pilot the balloon to safety
but he was unable to control it the
balloon was blown over the city of
brooklyn and landed in the middle of a
city street the pilot was knocked
unconscious by the impact
and the balloon was completely destroyed
it was the first time a hot air balloon
had been destroyed
and was a very significant loss for the
aeronautics community
there's a huge
there's a huge aeronautics community in
1880 dude
for the first time
ever died besides the one that the three
that napoleon destroyed yeah okay
uh
so anyways uh repeated the hot air
balloon of death story uh it was french
this time
uh just i can summarize it though it's
basically these guys had a close call
landed and they were fine and then it
just says five years later they were
killed in another hot air balloon
accident
oh here we go number two
hot air balloon of death two oh no the
sequel electric blue it's like we need a
title for this accident
like a hotter balloon of doom
1785 hot air balloon was built for jean
france
he wanted to use a balloon to take him
to the top of the cathedral of notre
dame in paris
he took the balloon to the top of the
church but he was not able to reach the
top of the spire
very pathetic flight i suppose the
balloon was too heavy to carry him high
enough to make it to the top of the
spire but he was still determined to
make it to the top he climbed
into the basket the balloon was filled
with hot air the balloon lifted off the
ground and when it reached 100 feet the
balloon exploded oh my god and he fell
to his death
and number one ladies and gentlemen
here's the hot air balloon of death
three oh
my god
oh no
hold on this is still about notre dame
refresh
you can do better than this
all right can we do it is the sequel
gonna be better let's see
1828
another french hot air balloon
it was larger than previous balloons and
it was designed in a way to make it
easier to control the balloon was filled
with air and it lifted off the ground
the balloon rose to 300 feet
but then the pilots decided to jump to
safety because the balloon continued to
rise and eventually exploded
the pilot's body was found a few days
later
and a crowd of people had gathered to
watch the balloon
what
did jump
that should have been number 10. that
sounds like some ai story writing yeah
well yeah i mean i refreshed it to see
if there's an alternate ending and there
was and it's uh the balloon exploded and
it was the first time an explosion
happened mid-flight with an air balloon
the pilot this time
did not die he was lucky enough to
survive the explosion but he was
severely injured he was taken to the
hospital where he was treated for burns
he eventually recovered but he was
unable to walk for a very long time
[Laughter]
and he was named jean-pierre blanchard
now okay and he went down in history as
the first man to fly in a hot air ball
wow
so it's actually drawing on some real
names here jean-pierre blanchard was a
french inventor best known as a pioneer
in balloon flight
oh my god who doesn't push himself in
the conquest of the air in a balloon in
particular the first crossing of the
english channel on 7 january 1785
before the balloon exploded and he
nearly escaped with his life okay let's
see if he died let's see if he died in
flight
let's see
like i literally just cried that was
amazing i can't help it every time wait
wait wait
20 february 1808 bonchard had a heart
attack well in his balloon he fell from
the balloon and died roughly a year
later due to severe injuries this is not
ai
oh my god wow his widow continued to
support him herself with ballooning
demonstrations until doing so also
killed her oh my god dude ballooning is
dangerous careful man when you go
yeah
maybe this is why i haven't booked it
yet dude never forget blanchard sandy
any more announcements to make well i
have a new announcement which is i've
decided
to postpone my hot air balloon ride
indefinitely
i don't know maybe
maybe there's other safer ways to get a
thrill
well it's it's really come full circle
all right i'll give it the i'll give you
guys this with that sad announcement
that i had to make i will
consult the ai and asked it ask it what
the safest way to get a thrill is
the safest
way early early balloon flights
triggered the phase of public balloon
mania
oh
that's a real thing okay
yeah i'm thinking polynomial everyone
away belong
established ballona mania here's the
safest way to get a good thrill
uh a safe car i guess
oh on a mountain bike there we go hey
you have one of those i already have one
there you go
all right well no balloons needed i
guess i i have all the tools to get a
thrill in my disposal already
all right well that's a great podcast
episode thanks for listening everybody
guys
after the invention of the modern
parachute in 1783
uh blanchard demonstrated it as a means
of jumping safely from the hot air
balloon oh really
his first his first parachute
demonstrations were conducted with a dog
as the passenger
huh
did the dog make it
uh
it doesn't say
because i am going to assume no
later he had the opportunity to try it
himself in 1793 his hot air balloon
ruptured and he used a parachute to
escape
oh he didn't judge safety
so this it was really okay it knows what
it's talking about the 1800s man ballona
mania yeah sounds wonderful i'm gonna
take everything he said that dude yeah
like new world it's like a really
intense drama about like these
backstabbing balloonists here right now
robert downey jr christian bale benedict
cumberbatch has to be in there
definitely yeah as the rogue one who's
like yeah he's like the rogue naysayer
he like creates a balloon that no one's
ever seen before and christianity he's
like really manic yeah people trying to
ask him about his balloon he just can't
ever give him the time and like no one
is concerned
no one is concerned enough about the
high risk of death other than other than
benedict
he's the only one who's taking it
seriously he's always stay at the sky
it starts with a montage of them as boys
looking at the sky and birds
it's like one day i had a dream
a dream of flight
oh hey there was another guy named
jeffrey's
sam
we're writing the movie let's do it
that's right
he's making tacos right now i need to
head home
see you
later
all right guys that's it next time
the dungeon comes out next week
son of a dungeon don't don't miss out
it's
crazy it's crazy
about ballona mania until christian
fades me out guys ballona mini was a
strong public interest or fad in
balloons that originated in france in
the late 18th century and continued into
the 19th century during the advent of
balloon flights
the interest began with the flights of
the montgolfier oh you got it you turned
it off i haven't yet
oh okay
don't stop jake don't stop there it is
okay
uh soon afterwards jacques alexandra
cesar charles flew another type of
balloon inflated with hydrogen and both
types of balloons were used from then on
the fad quickly spread in france and
across the channel in england
public responses early ballooning was
met with mixed responses crowds of
hundreds or thousands of enthusiastic
onlookers would turn out for a balloon
launch even threatening to riot if the
launch was delayed
some however were not quite as impressed
as shown by the events of august 27 1783
when professor john alexander cesar
charles who had been commissioned to
build a rival balloon to the
montgolfier's version of using hydrogen
launched his own balloon from the champ
de mar before a large crowd including
american scientist benjamin franklin the
balloon traveled for 45 minutes quote
and 15 miles to the village of genoese
where it was attacked by frightened
peasants upon landing
haircut